I'm I've lost count of how many threes
I've been to at this point it's just all
a blur
oh yeah my third I feel like the old guy
it's number three for you tomorrow did
you poop your pants during one now I'm
on my [ __ ] now on my first one I almost
pooped my pants
oh it was my third week working a game
spot we're trying to like territory how
many thousands of people are watching
just take a quick dump on the table now
it was like because Tyra was running
things then and I've never spoken to him
before and he was like you sit here you
do not move if you move you screw this
all up for us and I was like I really
need to go to the toilet badly and I was
sandwiched between I think I was next to
Kevin at the time and maybe Chris waters
was in the middle and you were on the
air and yes if you go back and watch
that stream just look into my eyes and
notice how much I'm readjusting the way
I'm sitting like it was trying to
compress everything and hold it in place
long enough once I was done I took them
best don't really excited for the
witcher 3 speaking of we could probably
get into what we're gonna see CD Projekt
RED has said definitely gonna be there
with an RPG right which everybody is
pretty much suing it's cyberpunk 2077 we
still don't exactly know what kind of
game it'll be I mean aside from an RPG
they've said that yeah sci-fi probably a
cyberpunk aesthetic I would imagine I
mean we don't know if it's gonna be in
the vein of The Witcher 3 I found a lot
of success with Witcher 3 they have to
emulate that it's gonna be hilarious
when it comes out it's an expansion for
gwyneth and everyone's like oh no I'll
be really good that's that's one of the
bigger things that we're expecting to
definitely see yeah absolute fallout 76
between 76 today yeah today as of this
recording in both 76 our future begins
there are sources saying it's gonna be
an online like survival game inspired by
dayz and rust yeah which I find pretty
cool but I imagine there will be some
backlash for people who just want that
Bethesda Game Studios single-player RPG
a lot of Fallout Elder Scrolls which
could still be coming yeah
I'm gonna teasing a lot of stuff before
that press conference I feel like
they're holding something back
yeah they have that one game which
they're supposed to be make your stars
something like that but like this
Fallout game seems like a natural
evolution of shelter and it's like they
did so well with shelter it makes sense
for them to kind of scale up then given
the trend of open world kind of survival
and almost like Daisy style stuff being
everywhere right now this is the game
that feels almost best to it to do it
like even if it's rubbish just someone
should do it just to say it's done
because we need that fallout open world
kind of a post-apocalyptic creation game
but yeah I get the feeling that there
will be some trepidation from people who
like I want a proper format okay well
are just something different yeah and
the fallout style well while we're on
Bethesda they also announced rage - with
that trap we know it's gonna be an open
world kind of game between collaboration
between Avalanche Studios and it yeah
that's about it right now we also know
it's a sequel to the 2009 game I'm still
surprised or doing a sequel to that but
I guess that just like shows some I
think they're just trying to play off
the recognition of the brand
I don't expect they're actually no it is
a brand that is known rightists ok no I
think that seriously like it's just
that's the bare minimum I think for a
publisher like that these days
especially the idea that it's going to
be different that at least gives people
some context to get excited for because
you know best-case scenario they hold on
to what did work about rage and just
spin the rest into somewhere new I get
the feeling like they're trying to eat
Borderlands lunch yes like just be like
because Borderlands is a game that
people really love but it's just the
kind of build up to it and the sequel
has been so slow and weird and muddled I
get the feeling that they could really
benefit off just coming in and being
like hey we've got a crazy apocalyptic
mad max-style game and obviously every
launch did Mad Max right so it's like
them being coming up and being like that
game that you like because it's kind of
madman
see we've actually got the people who
made the game and we taken the same
attitude and the style of it and I think
they could really slide in and kind of
like take some mindshare away from
Borderlands it depends on the timing
yeah because it's not a 20-18 game yeah
yeah but they were Andy Fisher just
speaking like we're not gonna be a three
now which kind of seems like that or did
he just say Borderlands three you think
he's so cool and so I think there'll be
some maybe there's Borderlands something
though and we caught Borderlands a
deferred I mean I was true I did a magic
trick did you see it
I'm grateful magic while we're on
Bethesda they've been teasing some prey
DLC news I forgot who reviewed for
GameSpot they were totally wrong it was
one of the best games last year hundred
percent always right that's good yeah
pray they're gonna have that moon DLC
everybody's pretty much like a poorly
kept secret they've been tweeting for
like maybe six months now
I shouldn't tweet about if they want to
keep it a secret right poorly kept
secret I said but I'm kept it'll I'm
personally excited to see what that is I
really like to pray I know there's a few
of us in the office that liked it I
don't know you at all Brogan's where we
are I'm really excited to see what they
do with presidency yeah how they add on
to it especially given how long it's
been since prey release now is anyone
really still thinking about that game or
how surprising it is that they're even
doing a DLC for that game which made
almost nothing in the grin like base
from arcane at least I'm wondering if
it's gonna be like a death of the
outsider kind of standalone expansion I
mean that was what I wanted them to do
when I first played pray but then I was
like I don't know if they made nobody do
that but then the festos been supporting
our King pretty well throughout the
years
yeah yeah they usually pull out good DLC
so I'm excited to see I'm interested in
going back to it because I'd love to see
how they whether they follow the same
style of the game or if they kind of
switch you up in terms of tone taking
your feedback into account yeah exactly
[Music]
those damn mimics at least make them
interesting in some meaningful way I'm
up for it but my dream would be to see
deep doom to the music like cuz when
Gordon yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like
when Pete Hines is like oh we're gonna
have our press conference here like mitt
Gord was like oh really
to get we play something so quick right
yeah no no no it's not oh they announced
the new quake last year then they yeah
champions completely forgot about it
right this moment so maybe we'll see
yeah I don't know there was like a beta
for that yeah okay all right I should
know these things
yeah but anyway moving on from Bethesda
we got EA will have anthem just this
morning as well they started they
tweeted out like it looked like kind of
a matrix looking code falling place
saying decoding twice you didn't see
that oh yeah I don't know what that's
gonna be about is just pretty much them
teasing that they're gonna be it III
like really interested in anthem cuz
like didn't thinking about Blizzard so
much recently I can't even say any other
B words by way has really taken it
the star has fallen for them this is
kind of to me a big make-or-break moment
for them
I give any tip out it's solid good game
that hooks people otherwise that the
prestigious time to kind of like fall
off around Bioware you ready to go just
grab my supplies just already what did
he lose today I decided to go with the
Colossus
I'm gonna use my ranger try out some new
upgrades yeah I'm curious to see like
how you know all the reaction to Star
Wars gonna happen see they're not
related but the economics of a game
coming out of EA especially a big one
like anthem I'm curious to see how
that's maybe shifted I guess we'll
probably never know what might have
changed and like I'm hoping they're
looking at destiny I mean they've had
two destinies to look at if that is the
type of game they're going for they've
had two destinies to look at and see
like what are the issues here what do
people like and kind of use that as a
jumping off point for their experience
so I'm hoping that in doing that and we
get something a little more you know
long-term out of it I really want to
kind of think myself into a new Bioware
world yeah I played Andromeda and it
crushed my soul that's the thing I don't
want to lose like everything that
usually makes a Bioware game special
which is its single-player and so I hope
we kind of get more details about how
that aspect of it cuz what was that game
they announced where it was like there
would be a single-player campaign but it
was like the asynchronous asymmetrical
multiplayer it's like shattered realms
so something like yeah yeah it was like
and they were gonna try and balance
multiplayer
I'm a single-player yeah I'm with you
though if they could take what people
like about destiny and those kind of
games and then implement it into the
Bioware formula which lately hasn't
really held much cloud like why always
trends is storytelling and
seek the single-player campaigns
destinies for me one of his biggest
weakness is that stuff is completely
throw away for me like I do not care
about anything that happens in destiny
beyond chewing stuff and getting new
loop so if they could come in and be
like hey we've created a good story in a
proper world for you to actually think
anything to you know more meaningful
than having the traveler just floating
there for no apparent reason for years
and years that could be a big deal in
for someone like me and I really hope I
love Byway and I want to see them
succeed I love most game companies don't
want to see them succeed more than
anyone I want to see by way kind of hit
their stride again cuz when Byway puts
out a good game it's like it's a special
thing I think that struck me when they
showed it off last year was the mobility
throughout the world yeah that's my big
question mark because that's the sort of
thing that can really hook me in a game
like that excellent feeling of movement
and and how the world can facilitate
that and allow you to go through it
right and experience all it has to offer
in different ways
that's clunky I would probably have to
not even I probably write it off even in
the story that's good and it's like they
don't have a great history with mobility
and that style if you think of the jet
pack or the Makos jet jet packs but this
looks so much more yeah it seems like
they must have like brought in new
people to do it yeah that wouldn't
surprise me good you have the upgrade
will be the GUP grades will all be based
on your exosuit right and there's other
four classes I forget what they're
actually called but you know obviously
destiny has the three so it does seem
like it is their destiny killer and if
you want to call it that to be reductive
but yeah we'll also be showing
battlefield 5 more of it at EA play the
weekend or the weekend at the beginning
of the ìiî
we saw that trailer they showed during
dices conference which didn't really say
much the trailer looked like an action
movie people that annoyed because they
didn't think it was historically
accurate which battlefield multiplayers
never been it's cuz they're idiots
Michael yeah I know
the thing that struck me about was it
was a little more playful than I
expected it to be like there was a bit
where the guy was like injured and a
medic was running by any of like I need
a med kit and the guy just replied like
Sorry mate no time it was like weirdly
fortnight ish in terms of the way it was
toned and like I was like oh this is an
interesting thing to lead with for
battle because usually they're like very
straight you know serious shooter doing
crazy things but being like tonally very
like this is a war we're gonna do war
stuff but here is like a little more
playful which is weird for me and I kind
of like it I like that a leaning into it
cause it that's ultimately what you want
to do right that gif of a guy on a horse
with a flamethrower is what I want to do
curate I still don't care it seems like
they're being more honest about how
people play those yeah I keeps running
of like a trevor in GTA 5 it's like a
character that makes sense where Enix is
having their own press conference this
year for the first time in a few years
we got Kingdom Hearts 3 it's probably
Lucy I know you want to talk about camp
March 3 I played it monk couple weeks go
into the event in Santa Monica
yep got to play if like an hour like if
you are familiar with Kingdom Hearts
then you'll be fine
but I am interested in seeing how people
you haven't grown up with Kingdom Hearts
are gonna take to it because it feels
very ps2 looks incredible hmm but also
and the way they tell the characters is
great like very very authentic like the
way they did the crew story characters
but at the same time they added in like
just the most incredible anime noise
like they will have a conversation
or something or like like yeah I don't
know and the writing is very much
you know that we took like someone's
gone missing and then you know sorrell
go but he's my friend
we have to go find him it's it's very
very corny Joe whatever but it is like
what Lisa said is her arm tattoo is it
feels like a Kingdom Hearts game the
cameras slightly wonky and requires a
little more micromanaging than you like
the combat is kind of like very flowy
and you know this time like the chain
style stuff which if you know Kingdom
Hearts it makes perfect sense and it
feels familiar but I'm interested I
think they're gonna really lean into
kind of selling the kind of attachment
characters more so than I have and I
think they it makes me think that
they're gonna have a lot of recent
popular characters like really frog
focus on like the frozen characters or
the tangled characters or whatever it
may be
yeah big hero 6 and use that to kind of
bring
more people in well that's good because
Kingdom Hearts like like the number just
one and two and then you had all those
spin-offs and they have used the same
world to death like I have to go to
Agrabah
one more time I swear to God it should
be fair I don't care about Katie parts I
seriously like it's about damn time that
they show something about Final Fantasy
7 remake yeah if they don't they've run
the serious risk of people just laughing
it then like more than they already are
they've they've changed teams once they
they could kick cyberconnect2 out they
have you know throwing around like
pretty broad statements about what the
game is gonna be and what its gonna
entail we have to see something and I
really hope it's not just another CGI
I hope it's not I get a feeling it will
be like there's something about that
that kind of stuff that changing teams
and that kind of business I feel like if
it required a kind of gameplay revamp or
sort of sorts they're gonna lean on
something easy easy sellable yeah but
like the thing that would really I think
it fans really stoked I don't know how
much you guys care about probably agency
7 right but like showing how the materia
system works how mixing and matching
materia
can then be turned into game play even
if it's just basic examples like that I
don't need like a 20 minute you know
it's like it could you know consecutive
like gameplay reporting like get into
the nitty gritty actually speak to the
fans I show something other than clouds
facing thing is like do you think they
would go as hard on Final Fantasy 7 if
they're gonna go oh I know right there
is that sort of I think it's only like
an hour as well as it's like yeah it's a
tough balance but they have other press
conferences as well it was obviously
Sony as they can lean into that yeah
obviously if Alec nice aesthetic could
appear at any of the publisher their
platform holders press conferences
his Lincoln 15 was on Microsoft yeah
right yeah and Microsoft needs to cater
to Japanese fans I think if they want to
stay competitive or they can just
continue down the path are doing right
now which is sort of you know taking a
breakout from Sony by giving people
services that work really well maybe
Microsoft can do something else along
that route I don't want to see another
halo 6 I don't I don't know what you
guys add well I don't care about
Microsoft sequels like that because oh
my god how many more games Rooney with
Master Chief specifically you know for 6
ah well that's happening 6 and like they
have to and that like I'd say guarantee
on Halo 6
I would not be totally surprised to see
Gears of War 5 announced for was how
many years ago - I think that like I'm
not I'm not disagreeing - I don't know I
know but I really like a lot of hate
from people just saying I don't give a
[ __ ] but like seriously like do
something surprising yeah I'm serious
because like scalebound I cancelled a
couple years ago that was a new IP
they're gonna show whoring the blind
forest - which I'm really excited for
but that's not huge no and I want
Microsoft to show something like crazy I
want them to surprise people because you
know it's every other everyone else does
yeah I want them they're gonna show helo
sticks are gonna show I they might show
gears more 5 or something you're gonna
show Orion blind forest - I want them to
surprise us to surprise us but I don't
know what they would show right now
high ground doing an open-world RPG was
playground the Forza horizon guys were
hiring for a not force a game at bay
I think as an RPG of sorts so that could
show I feel like it's still too early
for that to pop up but that could be one
of the things that they very briefly
teased but I agree with you like I will
play some halo if you put some halo in
front of me but if they show on the
stage I will not be excited I shall
crackdown 3 as well Amazon accounts lean
crackdown pre-orders for this year which
means another way then it could be
something to do with like Amazon and
Sony way like people's stuff is getting
cancelled
that's our icon I kiss a boy is fine but
I cannot deal with another Gears of War
being the centerpiece like they need
Microsoft really really need to show
they have games they bill a lot of
momentum by me sure their new ideas yeah
yeah they build some momentum by being
like hey Xbox one X which is the best
way to play you know 4k games or
whatever but like they've had little to
nothing to kind of like really entice me
into buying one of those I'm fine with
my current Xbox one X I need some new I
need some new games need some new IPs
need some new ideas and if they don't
have that I think they're gonna have a
really rough III I see if thieves was a
really great attempt yeah do something
do something as unexpected as that yeah
I think that's mine maybe not my number
one dream for this e3 but like I've I've
been pretty critical of Microsoft over
the years like a lot of people but i
think i i've always brooding for them
and I want them I think my number one
wishes this e3 is that like you said
Microsoft does something super
surprising and I'm happy coming out of
III about Microsoft
[Music]
all right what about Sony they've got a
few things we could talk about yeah
already said ghosts of Tsushima death
stranding spider-man and most of us -
yeah probably what a days gone as well
yeah he's gone metal so that's spring
2019 I believe Game Informer has had a
ton of footage I have never seen a game
like show that much yeah footage this
early oh it's more than that - they like
gave them each the controller for a
while I'm really excited for that game I
know like a lot people are tired of
zombies but I think if they can do new
things with that game the open world
survival which has been done but if they
can attributes enough new ideas I'll be
on board for that game next year
yeah I've been begging and pleading for
a new Tenchi game and although this
isn't that it's just close enough and
you know a stealth game that Studio
makes incredibly interesting open worlds
and they do traversal really well which
is one thing that we talked about before
like between infamous and sly and that
kind of stuff they do traversal so well
and the idea of like this you know the
samurai becoming a ninja story would the
stuff that could introduce without with
freerunning or even like I love the
intent you just grappling up onto a roof
running around and that was like my
favorite thing to do so that that game
is like all my attention is on that game
I want to see what it's got I love
stealth games what are the odds were
gonna see a gameplay of death training I
say no
I say no yeah hey Connie
just play devil's advocate what could
they show anything that would paint an
idea of what this game is I'm five
minutes yeah
outside of Kojima's you know like hey
guys smart but it's always like it seems
like delusions of grandeur at first
until we see more of whatever he's doing
every time I try to think about what
that game plan could be
I always just my frame of reference is
old metal gets tough yeah and the only
thing I can find in there is that and
they'll get solid three mini-games next
nightmare which is this the weird like
action game that you wake up into and
kill zombies and that kind of stuff so
that's currently my my kind of template
for what it could be but I don't I think
that's a bit too like open who has way
too simple like he's a whole like rope
and stick thing that years and going on
about four years I think we will see
gameplay of last Wes though yeah I feel
like this will be this is the perfect
time exact probably show closer maybe is
that this year still I reckon he'll be
next so much like I don't think it's
properly sad yeah at the tone of the
last two trailers especially last one
yeah they were going all in on the
brutal aspect of it yeah and we know I'm
doin le if they do the similar thing now
with that because there was quite a lot
of backlash to that trailer so I wonder
how they approach showing a new trailer
because if that is the overall tone of
the game like it's really war and you
know rough and then they'd have to
almost double down on it so it could
kind of define the discussion around
their press conference if they really do
double down on it then how are you gonna
balance that would like the levity of
spider-man like a hard cut off the
Spider Man long break where it's like
disclosure and then not
and just my disclosure thing it's been
like but all this is about to get bad so
careful
so spider-man will play later this year
right yeah November months p.m. Game
Informer showing stuff they show a lot
more than that game I'm excited for that
game I thought yeah I like insomniac
stuff yeah exactly worried about the
combat but yeah yeah traversals like
they do travel again very well and
there's some one of the things I really
hope they've done is like they're the
amazing spider-man games like there was
two of them they're not yeah right games
the activator they're not great games
but they did swinging really well in a
way it did like the behind the shoulder
camera and like when you swung you'd
come really close to the ground and it
like swing come up behind you and follow
you around
I think that's got some of the most some
of the best that momentum base swinging
and cinematics of it so I hope they
taking a cue from that and not so
they're like building their own combat
system I don't know how I feel it looks
like more is more environment based or
you're grabbing stuff and play yeah yeah
that works and it's written by it in
part by Dan Slott who wrote a superior
spider-man
and that is an excellent series so I'm
kind of hopeful for the actual story as
well right and superior spider-man was
Doctor Octopus becoming spider-man
because he's which buddy in the pee
epoxy he gets weird as well okay so it
could be interesting from a story
perspective
I'm moving on to the last of the big
three
we got Nintendo yeah what's your ass
bros just magic yeah we'll get back
smashes you know what smashing so much
my shirt primed for is the big question
yeah
who the hell is making it will it
actually start saying this because
there's a huge number of rumors pointing
to this new character Silex being
heavily involved what better way to
switch things up and to have that the
main character he is a bounty hunter he
is Sam's his adversary right maybe they
could work in tandem or maybe it'll be
against each other I would love to see
something crazy like that one of my
favorite Metroid games I know it's not a
popular one is Metroid Fusion yeah and
look like the evil Samus right I'd love
if they did that like propylene into the
survival horror angle and I have like an
evil Samoset again like parasite exams
rolling around in the metroid primes
though or maybe have sama since Alex's
backyard have sex just to sure that the
screw with you yeah to be a menace that
like treat treat another character like
the nemesis from Resident Evil or
parasites Emerson that is one of my
favorite games and I'd love for them to
switch you up I would love a different
character oh yeah cuz it's I love when
series kind of present a different take
on when a character you love and you
know maybe I started to work right and
everyone hates writing but the great
thing about writing is you get to
experience what it's like to be next to
snake yeah and there's few characters as
like competent and like revered as samus
so to be able to see her like operate
from another person's perspective would
be really interesting especially in a
game like program
yeah so I yes smash I don't think we'll
see much probably
oh you don't smash me I think this would
be the smash here and maybe some like
Mario stuff I as much as it I would hate
it the idea of it I don't think we gonna
see much crime just last night as it's
recording we saw all the Pokemon let's
go
Pikachu let's go Eevee news as well as
what Pokemon quests
yeah the mobile that's out today so
that's not the switch big switch title
they've been working on do you think
they'll show anything off with that e3
especially coming off these
announcements last night so soon after I
think they might leave these ones to
breathe and then they'll do a cursory
like oh but you know we're still working
on this I think the way that the Pokemon
go the two new go games look is that
they actually look what I was imagining
a switch Pokemon game yeah look like so
I don't imagine it could go too far away
from that and really wow us yeah so yeah
like you said let these breathe and sort
of use this as the foundation and take
the learnings from it to them it seems
like they're well they've said they're
also trying to introduce the huge
Pokemon go audience into more mainstream
or maybe not mainstream into more
mainline Pokemon games especially with
the actual capturing a [ __ ] on in the
game is more go influence it just sell
switches so there's people by other
games to that demon trick you know
because remember last year they revealed
the new Metroid game wouldn't no one was
looking
no and it came yeah once after so we've
got a fantastic they could do similar
things with that like I imagine it's
gonna be the smash show mostly but
people should be keeping an eye on the
treehouse stuff after with yeah they
always do say that your house for years
bring back wiring away they've already
talked about where you're really on 3d
yes
you think we'll see anything else from
the 3ds aside from that yes yeah yeah
miss Tendo is not quitting on that no
yeah I'm glad I love to read yes um but
as far as smash goes do you have a mind
that it'll just be the Wii U version
with new characters put on the switch or
like full-on Super Smash Bros skirmish
brouhaha they'll build on top of this
with the Wii U foundation there'd be no
reason to scrap it I don't think anyone
thinks that it's like worth starting
over oh yeah yeah I think the Wii U
version aside from melee is like one of
the more revered ones yeah and then they
could tweak it a little bit they
wouldn't have such a sad scratch yeah
it's like a fresh coat of paint and you
can I mean they've been making the same
game for years like so I'm sure if they
gave us the exact same game on which
most people would be happy but they'll
go into a bit the press conference that
we didn't talk about third-party Ubisoft
division 2 is probably their big thing
which I'm actually excited for I
returned to the division recently and
after all those updates I mean it was a
good game to begin with it just wasn't
what a lot of people expected I think a
lot of people expect its
post-apocalyptic co-op open-world
story-driven kind of thing I'm actually
pretty excited for the division 2 to see
what they do specifically with the dark
zone because that was a cool idea that
was like their you know their their
shared
multiplayer you can kind of turn on
people it was almost like a more
in-depth battle royale unless you turn
out people you can help them out usually
it was a little bit broken when I first
came out and now they've refined it but
I'm curious to see what they do with the
division to kind of build upon the
foundation it reminds me of destiny
because it was a lot of the ideas there
were new it didn't just seemed like they
were shaped to the way they needed to be
I'm curious if they'll go the destiny to
route and kind of backtrack a little bit
and annoy some people or if they'll just
keep building on the solid foundation
they've built especially after all those
expansions really interesting is like
between
and a lot of similar experiences coming
together who saw that I mean they're not
coming to games a long term so I expect
we'll spend some time on the existing
games like foreigner and siege
definitely there should be some awesome
stuff they're gonna have third year
whatever it also gonna have one last
push for crew to second yeah yeah bob
lands is still out there I don't know if
they how come it today to that they are
probably more wacky DLC maybe yeah like
apparently that like like division of
that game has changed significantly and
it's really good now it's one of those
games that I've been me to go back to
but that could get like a if they want
to show off that game and show like oh
this is better now and it's really cool
and there will be the five as well which
looks huge it's like an actual world but
then they have Mars and zombies yeah I
don't know what the order is I think I'd
mix those two up I really want to see
Splinter Cell along with I know like
cake is itself an it seems about time
and it's also they put Sam Fisher in
Ghost Recon wildlands yeah of all games
I would love to see them do a new main
line Splinter Cell last one with
blacklist which I really liked
it's not my favorite but it was really
good I would like to see them do
something new with that it's been a
while oh oh I thought you were saying
Elijah Wood would be in the new spooner
so amazing oh my god he's sam fish's son
sam has to kind of like train him to be
an operative from this what about what
about there like any watchdogs in the
Assassin's Creed this year Assassin's
Creed origins was the last two years ago
probably yes
it was last year's I took a year huh I'm
curious to see if they can build on the
momentum of origins or if they'll fall
back into that lackadaisical annual
release malaise yeah mouth full well big
words if they talked about like there
was a lot of discussion about
be moving towards a Witcher direction
and I think like if they I hope they
continue to move towards that way I
think origins was a good start for it I
think like some stronger quests and
strong a dialogue and like kind of
cleaning up the way kind of its
presented and like the ruffle you
there's moving on the rough edges there
if they keep going towards that I think
they'll be in a good place and hopefully
like this year's if they have won it
will be another step towards that so I'm
excited to see where they go because
it's gonna be good indication of what
Assassin's Creed future will look like
so if there's gonna be a set screen you
probably wouldn't expect anything from
watchdogs for a while then no I think
watch this is on watch those two did
well right and so I think they'll take
the time to build a build on that and do
something different they want to move
another say again these new characters
and stuff so good and evil oh yeah I
couldn't like after their announcement
did nothing for me in fact it actually
turned me off the game I was like it's
just he just seemed like everything that
everyone loved about Beyond Good and
Evil is missing raped out
watch your streams that they're doing as
well it's just like they're speaking and
they say something they're showing like
20 second long clips and I can't get a
feel for what it is and that every
original trailer when they were like the
Monkees are swearing and what he's like
oh you could go to there from the ground
to the ship and dogfights where I was
like what happened to just taking
pictures of animals and hearing people
with a stick my page so when do they
were first announced that that was like
lost that last year this last year in
position yeah I saw I went to see it and
that game did not exist like I was
looking at it that was not a game it was
an idea that someone had very quickly
called together in an engine and
they show me pictures like this is
artwork for it and I say there was no
clear vision of why it would be you know
answer was there talking and it was like
what is she was saying he was speaking
what he was saying was no making sense
at all and I don't feel like they've
moved forward in any meaningful work I
feel like they're kind of like they're
trying to cash in on trends almost like
this open world stuff and you freedom
and that kind of business but I don't
know why they've decided to attach
beyond good and evil to to like it's
nice I mean the reason I mean that is
the reason yeah but like it seems like a
really weird thing to do like it's going
on here anything about it yeah maybe we
want I feel like if they did it'll be
another short thing like a trailer and
they'll talk about they'll talk a lot
about it but we will still leave that
presentation not knowing what Beyond
Good and Evil 2 is and worst case not
one thing beyond evil - all right as far
as my I'm most excited for I don't know
if it's gonna be there I would love to
see a new main line Splinter Cell that
is my I think that's my dream
announcement this III tomorrow what are
you most excited for FEMA like I spent
it so again but another stealth game and
that studio is incredible so I'm excited
for Gulf of Tsushima I want to see more
of Last of Us and I want a release date
for Kingdom Hearts it's been twelve yes
twelve yes
and you recently played it yeah which to
be honest I did not expect I get me I
warned you it was like it was a moment
like you put the headphones on I was
like okay I still care it was they play
dearly beloved at the title screen and I
remembered that I care how much I care
about it when it's like playing and I
was like yeah it's cuz I played to a
very formative part of my life and I
just feel like that's I'm so
intrinsically tied to at least that song
in that game yeah I judge it and also
it's because it's taking the basemap I'm
just I'm the same with no get to so
whenever I see writing this flip on bad
[ __ ] Peter Brown what about you this
year uh for me I'm so Nintendo dork I
really want to see exactly everything
they're gonna show if I had to sort of
assume that someone announced thing you
know would materialize I would hope it
is a Zelda on 3ds that incorporates some
of the elemental mixing from breath of
the wild interesting way I think that
that could be a thing if they want to
keep people interested in true yes it's
almost probably the way to do it I mean
between worlds like going back in 3d oz
is one of my favorites elbows I mean
well hopefully this one cool well III
zan what as of this recording eat the
reason like ten days ten days
nice big clock over there oh yeah well
I'm looking forward to it and I'm hoping
we see more just dance don't you I will
do my best not to it don't prove
yourself yeah um at least when I'm on
set no promises
[Music]